Just heat it up at 300 and leave it in for 35 minutes. Thanks Karen. It's my take on Mexican lasagna
Great Jeff, and I can't imagine what you're going through. Well, it's like if Jeff got hit by a car and died suddenly and violently
Like that
Well, you get that dish back to me whenever you can
door cracking
music
Welcome to friends at heaven looks like we have so many people here today. I'm Judy Jones. I hope this isn't weird
Can I give you a hug? No?
Okay. I lost my fiance eight weeks ago was really sudden
crying
Had died. I got been sleeping. Not at all. Okay, I'm off all night. Feel free to call me. We can sleep together
phone ringing
Hi
Did you get it say him? No, that's my other husband. Oh and another one and you're fine. You are you in bed? Yeah
What are you wearing?
parents, but this
Slower, huh?
heh?
You're a weird person judy
They do this a lot just every time I see a person sized dent in the front bumper of a car
But it must be hard to be alone in that big house without Steven. My guest house is open be nice having you there
Boys, this is Judy. Hey, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He thinks that the bird this is that alert. Maybe it is him
Yeah, it's weird being in there
what! Holy fuck
You don't even know her she could be a crazy person who knows we're looking for Judy heyels . Hey, why are you looking for Judy?
Let's just say that wherever Judy goes chaos tends to 5
music
Because kind of game that you're playing with there's a lot of shit you don't know
Brave doesn't hurt its people. I know you you're crazy. I'm not
You invited a criminal into your home she's the only person who's been here for me
That doesn't make me feel like I am failing at everything
slow down! car braking
I've got a widow running around town like a white wine. vigilante, fuck!
breaking car mirrors
Fucking love you I
I Miss you, baby. Just wanted to say that okay fine. It's trying a thing. Fuck you, too